Most couch-potatoes have probably at some
point in their lives said, “I can’t run
a mile without feeling like I’m going to
die!”
They might also sarcastically proclaim they
must be allergic to exercise.
And, amazingly enough, it turns out there
is a rare disorder in which someone can be
deathly allergic to exercise, a condition
known as Exercise Induced Anaphylaxis (EIA).
Allergies, in general, come with a wide range
of symptoms, and can range from mild to deadly.
Fortunately for most, a deadly allergic reaction,
known as anaphylaxis, is rare.
It’s generally accepted anaphylaxis affects
approximately 2% of the population and EIA
is thought to represent only about 5%-15%
of all of those anaphylactic cases.
Interestingly, of those, women seem to be
twice as likely to suffer from it, than men.
It’s important to note that although the
symptoms of anaphylaxis can be brought on
by exercise, exercise itself might not be
the only cause of the reaction; typical allergy
mediators like foods, pollens and medications
when combined with exercise may result in
such a reaction.
Among these, food dependent exercise induced
anaphylaxis is the most common, accounting
for 1/3 to 1/2 of all EIA cases.
In essence, your body can handle the offending
food, and it can handle exercise, but when
you combine them, you get an over-reaction
of your immune system.
So what’s going on here?
Our immune system is extremely complex and
requires numerous types of cells and molecules
working together to fight off a foreign pathogen.
Any reaction from your immune system is generally
divided into two different categories- innate
and adaptive, both of which have specific
types of cells working in response to an infection.
All of these cells are broadly classified
as white blood cells.
An innate immune system reaction uses cells
that can recognize several different types
of foreign invaders, pathogens like viruses,
bacteria, and fungi.
It can be activated by some non-infectious
problems, like simply being exposed to cold
or hot temperatures, and even just pumping-some-iron!
The specific types of innate immune system
cells include basophils, eosinophils, neutrophils,
monocytes and mast cells.
Adaptive immune cells, on the other hand,
react to specific pathogens.
Usually produced by your lymphatic system,
they’re known as B and T cells.
While they work differently, both B and T
cells have the same goal- defend the body
against specific types of invaders.
Your immune system can make T and B cells
that match the surface molecules of invading
pathogens, with the T and B cells able to
quickly multiply, producing large numbers
of identical cells that can recognize and
destroy the foe.
B cells do not directly attack infected cells,
rather they primarily produce antibodies-
unique protein molecules that attach to specific
harmful pathogens, called antigens.
This antibody acts like a red-flag to T cells
(and other disease killers known as phagocytes)
to recognize the foreign body and destroy
it.
Once the infection disappears, memory B cells
can stay around for years, sometimes throughout
your entire life.
If the same invader appears, it will once
again mobilize and attack the pathogen.
Produced by your Thymus (thus T cell), T cells
come in several different types, performing
different functions.
Helper T cells produce chemicals triggering
B cells to develop into plasma cells.
Killer T cells target and kill cells that
have become infected or are cancerous.
Regulatory T cells help control your immune
systems reaction, preventing it from getting
out of hand.
Memory T cells, like memory B cells, stick
around for a while, quickly reacting should
the same invader appear.
When your immune system reacts to an allergy,
it can present with symptoms ranging from
mild to life threatening.
The more common, less problematic symptoms
are things like fever, cough, runny nose,
itchiness, hives and general body aches.
These mild symptoms usually don’t require
a visit to the doctor, and if annoying enough,
you might treat with over the counter medications
like Benadryl, Tylenol or ibuprofen.
Should your immune reaction continue, or become
out of control, it can progress to anaphylaxis.
Generally accepted as life-threatening, this
reaction is more systemic and involves several
organs and body systems.
It can produce more severe symptoms like nausea
and vomiting, abdominal pain and dizziness.
It can also result in difficulty breathing
from swelling in the face, throat and lungs.
Your veins and arteries might begin dilating
to the point that your blood pressure becomes
extremely low and you pass out.
All of this can progress to rapid heart rates,
cardiac dysrhythmias and even cardiac arrest.
Anaphylaxis (or any lesser immune response)
caused by exercise isn’t different from
any other anaphylactic reaction.
It was first reported in the Journal of Allergy
and Clinical Immunology in June of 1979.
The authors described a case where a patient
had an anaphylactic reaction to shellfish,
but the reaction didn’t occur until the
patient went for a run.
The authors further noted the allergic reaction
was only mild and well tolerated when the
patient ate shellfish without exercise.
If he didn’t eat shellfish, he could run
without issue.
When combined, however, the patient would
have an anaphylactic reaction.
Since this 1979 report, there have been numerous
accounts of patients who have had anaphylactic
reactions from exercise, including recognizing
the link between food and other allergies
when combined with exercise- as previously
mentioned with food dependent seemingly the
most common.
To be specifically diagnosed with EIA, you
need to have symptoms of anaphylaxis associated
with exercise.
The cause must also be differentiated from
an anaphylactic reaction due to food dependent
anaphylaxis or being exposed to an allergen
before the workout.
It should also be noted that EIA can be brought
on by things some people might not consider
strenuous, like a mild stroll in the park,
though it’s much more commonly seen when
a more aggressive workout is attempted.
Interestingly enough, the reaction is also
not always repeatable- the same exercise causing
it today, might not cause it tomorrow.
This brings us back around to what exactly
is going on in the body to cause this.
While the specific factor, or factors, producing
exercise induced anaphylaxis aren’t proven,
it’s generally agreed among researchers
that histamine release is the key component
in the reaction.
Histamine is known as an autacoid, which acts
like a hormone, only it has a more localized
reaction.
It’s released from the innate immune system
cells, Basophils and mast cells.
The process is called degranulation.
Once secreted, histamine helps increase the
absorption of allergens to the body’s organs,
like the skin.
Once there, other mast cells get stimulated
to degranulate by an antibody (immunoglobulin
isotope) known as IgE.
IgE attached to mast cells has long been known
to signify an acute allergic reaction.
The acceptance of histamine being the mediator
in EIA, comes from the fact there is an increase
in plasma histamine, along with the IgE being
present on mast cells within the skin, in
patients experiencing EIA.
These patients also tend to be more susceptible
to degranulation of their mast cells and basophils,
compared to people who don’t have EIA.
The reason for this lowered threshold, and
the exercise-specific reason for degranulation
producing histamine, hasn’t been proven.
There are some widely accepted theories, however.
They include- increased gastrointestinal permeability
(absorption), blood flow redistribution, increased
osmolality, and increased endogenous endorphin
release.
In slightly more layman’s terms- exercise
increases the absorption of nutrients and
other molecules from the GI tract.
The speculation is then that allergens will
have greater contact with the parts of the
immune system associated with the gut, which
happens to be a lymphoid organ.
(Probably nature’s way of protecting us
from the many potential pathogens we put in
our mouths.)
As for blood-flow redistribution, this is
thought to contribute because, during exercise,
it’s redirected from inactive tissues like
those found in your digestive tract, to active
tissues like those found in your skeletal
and muscle tissues.
Those tissues mast cells are different from
the ones found in your GI tract.
So the thinking is that as long as a food
allergen remains in the gut and only exposed
to those types of mast cells, it doesn’t
cause histamine release.
But should it go to the skeletal muscles and
skin, those mast cells will degranulate and
cause a reaction.
Exercise also causes the release of endorphins,
giving you the same type of feeling taking
morphine would.
The release of these endorphins has been known
to enhance mast cell degranulation.
It seems reasonable then that the aftermath
of this increased endorphin release would
escalate the degranulation of mast cells,
resulting in a histamine response that causes
the cascading effects of anaphylaxis.
This brings us to the final, forerunner in
the theories of why certain people get EIA,
involving increased osmolality in your intestines-
meaning there is more allergen getting to
certain areas of your intestines, specifically
the worm-like processes called villi, in your
small intestines.
It’s thought, when you exercise, the mast
cells at the bases of your villi get exposed
to more of an allergen.
This exposure then secretes histamine, which
in turn results in an increased distribution
of allergen to many of the body’s organs,
such as skin, and the cascading effects of
histamine then produce anaphylaxis.
No matter the exact cause, the treatment for
EIA is the same as any other anaphylaxis-
avoid repeating the same behaviors causing
a reaction in the first place.
As any good doctor would say, “If it hurts
to do that, stop doing that”.
For those who want to “do that” anyway,
recent evidence has suggested that pre-treating
people with agents that inhibit cell degranulation
may prevent food dependent EIA.
Should you unsuccessfully avoid experiencing
anaphylaxis, I’d recommend calling 911.
The doctor, or paramedic, will treat the life-threatening
symptoms, like the swelling in your respiratory
tract and extreme low blood pressure, first,
usually using medications like epinephrine,
albuterol and atrovent.
They will then attempt to stop histamines
cascade of death, with antihistamines like
Benadryl, and corticosteroids like Prednisone
or Solu-Medrol.
In the end, yes, a person can be allergic
to exercise.
But as it’s an exceptionally rare condition,
should your body mass index be higher than
your age, you probably aren’t one of those
who can use it as an excuse not to hit the
gym.